[Musique]
Macron à Rungis qui parle valeur travail
pour sortir de la séquence retraite
cette séquence retraite justement qui
déchire la droite et enfin des
inquiétudes sur l'influence de l'eau
bises étrangers sur la France
mais d'abord donc merci président
Larcher la guerre de retour en Europe
depuis déjà un an c'est le 24 février
2022 que la Russie a attaqué l'Ukraine
cette semaine la Vladimir Poutine a
prononcé un nouveau discours offensif
envers l'Occident Joe Biden lui a
répondu depuis la Pologne où il était en
visite officiel écouté
occidentales ne cachent pas leur
objectif d'infliger une défaite
stratégique à la Russie c'est ce qu'ils
disent mot pour mot c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ont l'intention de transformer un
conflit local en une confrontation
globale c'est ainsi que nous le
comprenons et nous réagirons en
conséquence
il ne doit y avoir aucun doute notre
soutien l'Ukraine de faiblira pas l'OTAN
ne sera pas divisé et nous ne nous
lasserons pas
Chloé comment est-ce qu'on sort de cette
guerre
si c'était si simple de répondre à cette
question je pense que on le saurait
c'est un triste anniversaire
effectivement il y a un an on se
trouvait dans un pays la France sur un
continent l'Europe qui n'avait pas été
capable de prévenir que cette guerre
allait arriver dans une forme de déni
assez assez affligeant et on pensait que
en trois jours nous allions être
condamnés à assister à la fin de
l'Ukraine libre et au meurtre de son de
son président lucrètes
l'Ukraine est debout et le monde a
changé l'Europe surtout a commencé à
changer comment sortir de ce conflit on
sait bien que il y a plusieurs façons de
le faire soit une négociation soit un
armistice ou en fait il y a une des deux
parties qui dit stop je peux plus pour
l'instant c'est loin d'être le cas il y
a une forme d'équilibre des forces mais
je crois que après les armes et les
sanctions qui étaient deux piliers
nécessaires de notre riposte et de notre
résistance qu'il faut opposer à Vladimir
Poutine parce que faut-il le rappeler
humilié ni écrasé qui que ce soit il
faut simplement que notre pouvoir arrête
le pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine pour
paraphraser Montesquieu et pour ça il
faut soutenir ce qui lui résiste donc on
a envoyé des armes à la résistance
ukrainienne on a on a enfin mis les
sanctions à l'encontre de la Russie et
maintenant je crois qu'il faut faire
plus pour
isoler la Russie sur la scène
internationale et pardon je termine
rametez le sud global
dans la condamnation de ce qui est une
guerre impérialiste et c'est pour ça que
je crois que la rhétorique de
Occident versus Russie n'est pas la
bonne parce que c'est précisément celle
qu'attend Vladimir Poutine depuis le
début et ce serait une très mauvaise
manière de procéder puisque ça
remettrait la Chine dans le conflit et
nous ne voulons certainement pas de ça
donc il faut aujourd'hui faire beaucoup
plus pour convaincre la communauté
internationale de d'isoler la Russie
Fabrice est-ce qu'il y a une sortie de
crise même à oriaison un horizon
possible un moyen terme et comment
est-ce que vous voyez les choses il y a
plein de héros il y a plein de verrous
il y a un premier verrou qui celui qui a
déclenché la guerre en 2014 et là depuis
un an qui est Poutine qui est qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans sa tête quel est son
schéma est-ce qu'il est dans le verrou
du conflit c'est un premier verrou et
qui est pas et qui est pas des moindres
qui a un verrou lourd parce que il a
quand même c'est les gens ils ont
tendance à reproduire les succès qu'ils
ont eu dans sa tête la Tchétchénie a été
un grand succès il est arrivé au pouvoir
grâce à elle il a conduit le conflit
jusqu'à la fin ça a duré 10 ans la
deuxième guerre de Tchétchénie 99-2009
donc il a peut-être ce schéma là en tête
à se dire peut-être que je vais durer
peut-être que en attendant à la fin je
vais arriver après il y a d'autres
verrous comme vous avez dit des verrous
de géopolitique internationale et puis
il y a un dernier verrou qu'on
sous-estime souvent qui est l'Ukraine
qui est la volonté de Zelensky aussi et
de son peuple est-ce qu'ils veulent
récupérer l'intégralité du pouvoir du
territoire est-ce qu'ils veulent aller
moi c'est c'est une des une des clés
donc c'est cette combinaison qui va être
difficile pour ouvrir la porte de la
paix Nicolas vous pensez que le verrou
principal c'est pout est-ce que il peut
y avoir une négociation et ce qui peut y
avoir un moment on se met autour de la
table tous ensemble pour discuter sur la
sortie de police si vous voulez ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui c'est une escalade
et une escalade qui est quand même
pilotée par la Russie avec la
mobilisation de 300000 hommes puis de
500000 hommes donc il y a une il y a 850
morts par jour aujourd'hui côté russe
c'est un carnage qui est inimaginable et
la profondeur historique de l'Ukraine
elle elle vient de l'aide que nous
pouvons lui apporter de l'aide à la fois
financière évidemment surtout militaire
donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement il faut être clair on
est dans un moment qui est un moment
militaire et pas un moment diplomatique
parce que pour être dans le moment
diplomatique ce qui a été dit soit il y
en a un qui gagne et pour l'instant ça
n'est pas le cas soit les deux sont
d'accord pour discuter pour l'instant
aucun des deux soit il y a un tiers qui
est capable d'imposer sa médiation pour
l'instant il y en a pas puisque la Chine
en réalité
et de plus en plus proche
de la de la Russie et que le café des
propositions de sortie
c'est tout sauf un plan de paye et
derrière je je suis plus pessimiste que
vous c'est-à-dire que je pense que le
monde a changé mais que évidemment ça
dépasse souhaitable mais qu'il faut être
très clair on va dans une nous sommes
entrés dans une grande concentration
entre les démocraties et les empires
autoritaires et qu'on ne le chose est-ce
qu'on souhaite et une autre chose est-ce
qu'il se passe le rapprochement entre la
Chine et la Russie et le degré
d'agressivité contre les démocraties
malheureusement avec la tentative de
récupérer effectivement une partie du
Sud malheureusement c'est ce avec quoi
il va falloir
il va falloir vivre et de plus en plus
on voit que cette alliance elle devient
une alliance militaire si les Chinois
font ce qui est annoncé c'est à dire que
il livre massivement des drones tueurs à
la Russie on va on va vraiment changer
de parce qu'il y aura des
sanctions on aura des sanctions
américaines et occidentales derrière
mais cette fois-ci sur la Chine et donc
cet engrenage qui pour l'instant est
militaire sont très sur l'Ukraine avec
quand même la guerre hybride de chez
nous mais là on va de plus en plus faire
une confrontation
pour répondre directement à votre
question je pense que malheureusement
cette guerre elle va durer il y a un an
on aurait jamais pensé que on serait
encore là aujourd'hui et je pense que ça
va continuer pourquoi est-ce que ça va
continuer parce que aucun des deux camps
ne pense ni ne peut perdre cette guerre
en fait c'est à dire que aujourd'hui le
rapport de force sur le terrain les deux
ont la conviction qu'ils peuvent gagner
personne aucun des deux Candy la Russie
ni l'Ukraine ne pense qu'il peut perdre
les deux pensent qu'ils vont gagner et
politiquement
géopolitiquement aucun des deux camps ne
peut perdre non plus Vladimir Poutine ne
peut pas perdre parce que c'est son
pouvoir personnel qui est en jeu parce
que la Russie son peuple et la
population russe n'accepterait pas une
défaite on sait que dans l'imaginaire
russe la défaite militaire c'est ce
qu'il y a de pire et que les les
dictateurs changent toujours à cette
occasion là et l'Ukraine ne peut pas
perdre c'est l'inscris ne peut pas
perdre parce que qu'on le veuille ou non
et c'est la situation aujourd'hui tout
l'Occident est derrière lui a commencé
par Joe Biden dont on a vu l'extrait et
ma conviction profonde c'est que tant
que Joe Biden sera président des
États-Unis et donc il y en a au moins
encore pour deux ans il ne lâchera pas
l'Ukraine il va continuer à guerroyer
derrière le crâne donc on voit bien
qu'on a deux forces extrêmement opposées
extrêmement lourde avec des réserves
encore très importantes parce que les
Russes ont des réserves en homme en 19
et les Ukrainiens aussi et qu'ils vont
continuer malheureusement cette guerre
qui est qui est terrible parce qu'elle
elle fait des milliers de morts et que
c'est
juste après Nicolas très rapidement
dans la lignée de ce que vous avez
montré c'est par ailleurs sur les deux
camps il faut bien voir que le en fait
la vraie négociation elle sera entre la
Russie et les États-Unis c'est ce qui se
joue derrière effectivement mais alors
justement quel peut être le rôle de la
France dans cet échiquier internationale
oublier complètement les propos de juin
dernier sur le fait de ne pas vouloir
humilier la Russie maintenant Emmanuel
Macron est clair il dit vouloir la
défaite de la Russie en Ukraine il dit
je veux que l'Ukraine puisse défendre sa
position je ne pense pas comme certains
et qu'il faut défaire la réussite
totalement l'attaquer sur son sol cela
n'a jamais été la position de la France
cela ne le sera jamais et enfin de dire
toutes les options autre que Vladimir
Poutine au sein du système actuel et
bien tout ça ça lui paraît pire et bien
là-dessus vos lumières zaninsky a
répondu au Corée de la Serra et en
disant Zelinski il a dit que tout cela
c'était une perte de temps de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron Chloé qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez de cette séquence qui
s'est joué entre les deux les deux
dirigeants moi je pense que le discours
de de Biden en Pologne a totalement
éclipsé les discours du chancelier
Scholt et du président Macron à la
conférence de sécurité de Munich et je
le déplore parce que l'Europe est
totalement éclipsée alors Dieu fait des
maladresses il y avait un boulevard pour
que Macron incarne le lit que la France
incarne le leadership dans ce nouveau
contexte après
il fait des erreurs il parle trop etc
même si ce qui dit au fond à du sens
mais moi en fait le problème dans cette
séquence c'est que l'Europe se retrouve
noyée dans l'Occident et c'est mauvais
c'est précisément ce que veut Vladimir
Poutine Vladimir Poutine ne fait que
parler d'Occident il ne parle jamais
d'Europe alors même que son réel ennemi
c'est l'Europe puisqu'il a déclenché
cette guerre contre l'Europe et contre
l'attractivité qu'elle exerce sur
l'Ukraine et sur les pays qui
considèrent comme étant sa propriété au
sein du monde russe et aujourd'hui
l'Europe a disparu et donc je pense que
nous de d'activer cette rhétorique qui
sert Poutine notamment dans son dialogue
avec les
ce qui est très intéressant c'est
d'abord l'Europe s'est découverte
complètement vulnérable et des armées si
les États-Unis n'avaient pas soutenu
l'Ukraine l'Europe n'avait pas les
moyens de faire quoi que ce soit c'est
le principal fournisseur de d'armes loin
devant les autres pays
oui et puis surtout au-delà des armes il
y a le renseignement
du satellite jusqu'au smartphone bon et
donc l'Europe elle est elle s'est
découverte extrêmement vulnérable et
elle fait partie aussi des des grands
perdants ensuite elle est divisée et
c'est quand même très intéressant de
voir si vous regardez Joe Biden il aura
fait deux voyages en Pologne il est pas
venu ni en France ni en Allemagne et il
a fait Pologne
Ukraine et dans quelques on va quand
même se retrouver dans quelques années
dans la situation où les trois premières
années d'Europe ce sera la Pologne
l'Ukraine et la Turquie quant à la
France il est clair que on touche la la
limite et les contradictions du en même
temps on peut pas aller à Munich et dire
l'inverse dans l'avion et si vous voulez
derrière le en même temps je pense qu'il
y a une erreur complète c'est que c'est
cette notion de puissance d'équilibre on
n'est pas puissance d'équilibre dans un
monde en guerre dans un monde en guerre
il faut choisir son camp il il faut être
clair il y avait effectivement et on est
la grande conférence de l'OTAN à Munich
et dans le dans l'avion qui le ramène de
Munich effectivement Emmanuel Macron qui
parle à trois journalistes de France
Inter du JDD et qui donc nuance sa
position en disant qu'il y a bien qu'il
faut prendre en compte la lumière
Poutine et qu'il faut continuer à lui
parler en quelque sorte qu'est-ce que
vous avez vu cette séquence vous non
mais le problème c'est ce que vient de
dire Nicolas c'est à dire que depuis un
an et encore on est gentil quand on dit
depuis un an depuis 5 ans la position
française elle est compliquée à
l'échelle internationale elle est
ambiguë on essaye on peut pas faire du
en même temps à l'échelle internationale
et à force d'avoir ces espèces de
prudence entre avoir une stratégie de
domination une stratégie d'influence une
stratégie de puissance ou au contraire
être un état qui se met en retrait qui
se présente comme étant soutien on a
perdu une grande partie de notre
influence en Afrique il faut quand même
dire la vérité
on parle du Mali mais Burkina
Centrafrique et on voit qu'il y a
d'autres points qui sont encore très
très fragiles aujourd'hui
on critique des dictateurs qu'on qu'on
qu'on qu'on soutient et avec dont on a
besoin type Paul Biya type Bongo voilà
donc on est on est dans cette espèce
d'ambiguïté qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas
à marquer et là encore sur la question
je comprends la critique de l'Occident
que vous menez et la logique est là mais
la réalité en même temps c'est que
l'Occident s'est reconstitué à la faveur
de cette guerre c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
un bloc nous est défavorable
historiquement peut-être peut-être
trouver un autre nom mais la réalité
c'est aussi ça et c'est que si on n'est
pas dans ce bloc là avec les États-Unis
si on n'est pas dans ce bloc là derrière
l'Ukraine oui mais oui mais en attendant
l'alliance était nécessaire là derrière
l'Ukraine et et le manifester de manière
et le manifester de manière un peu plus
nette je pense aurait été meilleur de la
part de Macron très rapidement Valérie
je tiens quand même à noter parce que ça
pas été fait le fait que Joe Biden se
soit déplacé de cette façon là c'est
quand même un truc historique en fait
absolument et se dire le fait qu'il est
qu'il soit arrivé avec ses 80 ans là
après avoir donné il a fait 10 heures de
train il a pris un avion jusqu'en
Allemagne après il a repris jusqu'en
Pologne de la Pologne à l'Ukraine à Kiev
il est arrivé après c'est 10h de train
c'était un moment sincèrement je trouve
que c'était un moment d'une force d'une
puissance politique internationale je
l'ai les gens qui qui critiquaient Biden
Trump qui disait que c'était un faible
et un machin non c'est quelqu'un qui a
été extrêmement présent et ça a été
symboliquement très très important
il fait pas doute que la France a raison
de plaider pour un pilier européen et
notamment une Europe plutôt autonome et
un pays européen de défense parce que
les États-Unis on voit bien la fragilité
la volatilité de leur vie politique et
puis parce que leur vrai priorité c'est
la Chine cela dit on est dans une
situation où premièrement on est les
seuls à penser ça pour l'instant et
qu'il y a une notation de l'Europe à
cause du choc de l'Ukraine et surtout
pour plaider ça encore faudrait-il qu'on
soit crédible pour l'instant on n'est
pas sur le fond et même et sur le et sur
les armées très franchement au-delà des
annonces de 413 milliards de d'euros de
lois de programmation militaire mais on
sait pas ce qu'il y a dedans et donc là
aussi il y a une immense légèreté
de cette émission cette semaine on a vu
les critiques fusées envers Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le leader de la France
insoumise dans le leader historique du
parti est sous le feu des critiques
notamment des syndicats après la
séquence sur la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale écoutez le
spectacle qui est donné à l'Assemblée
nationale il est indigne il est honteux
il fallait aller à l'article 7 c'est un
double problème je vous dis le premier
problème c'est un délai contraint on
peut pas avoir un délai contraint en
termes de procédure parlementaire sur un
sujet aussi important que les que ce que
cette réforme de retraite le deuxième
problème c'est le comportement de
certains députés notamment de la France
insoumise qui ont considéré que
l'obstruction était plus contre la vie
de toutes les organisations syndicales
étaient plus bénéfiques que d'aller à
l'article 7 ce qui a été fait à
l'Assemblée nationale et le fait de ne
pas aller à l'article 7 pour que chacun
puisse afficher ses positions c'est un
problème est-ce que c'est un allié du
mouvement social Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quand il fait des choses comme ça non il
ne favorise pas la clarté des débats la
clarté des positions
l'article 7 qui est évoqué par les deux
syndicalistes c'est celui sur le recul
de la mesure d'âge Chloé et on voit
qu'il y a comme ça deux tactiques
différentes et cinq casques sont très
critiques en vergeant avec Mélenchon moi
j'irai une chose très simple le fait que
l'article 7 n'est pas été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale pour moi est un
marché
le fait que l'article 7 n'est pas été
voté à l'Assemblée nationale pour moi
est un échec démocratique
parce que ça porte atteinte à la
transparence et en tant que citoyen moi
j'aurais aimé voir qui aurait voté pour
cette pour cet article et ça bien des
gens chez LR et dans la majorité de ne
pas voter cet article maintenant à qui
la faute si cet article n'a pas été voté
je vois qu'on met beaucoup d'accent sur
la stratégie qui a été celle de la Nupe
c'est celle de LFI j'entends que
peut-être que c'est pas la stratégie
optimale mais pour moi la faute elle
incombe quand même au choix du
gouvernement dans sa procédure dans le
choix de la procédure parlementaire à
travers l'article 47.1 le fait que on
est si peu de jours pour examiner un
texte aussi important et donc c'est tous
les éditeurs mettre l'accent mettre la
faute sur la nuque mais je suis désolé
la faute première elle est du côté du
gouvernement d'avoir choisi cette
procédure parlementaire là oui
parce que je pense qu'en termes de
stratégie parlementaire il aurait été
quand même plus avisé de la part de la
nupeuse sachant que la procédure choisie
par le gouvernement a été celle là et
après tout s'est constitutionnel et ils
pouvaient le faire ça aurait été plus
intéressant de choisir une tactique
différente de celle qu'ils ont choisies
parce que faire obstruction absolument
en permanence ça a été une catastrophe
ce que dit Laurent Berger ce que dit
Laurent Berger est extrêmement important
quand ils disent ils ont donné un
spectacle honteux oui c'est vraiment
dommage et c'est tellement dommage que
qui va bénéficier de cette attitude ça
exaspéré les Français de voir que tout
le monde s'investitait que tout le monde
était furieux on comprenait plus rien
mais je suis pas sûr ça reflète aussi un
certain état d'esprit des Français
du gouvernement c'est juste que toute la
terre est mis dans le temps des
oppositions
dans cette situation en fait il voulait
c'est que il y a une il y a un parti qui
a profité de tout ça c'est le
rassemblement national c'est la triste
vérité de ce qui s'est passé et c'est ce
que souligne et la faute à qui la faute
à qui la faute au parlementaire de la
nupestre
mais bien sûr que oui il le savait qu'il
y avait qu'il y avait 9 jours de débat
et au lieu de se focaliser sur le
principal et de le faire de façon
responsable en responsabilité les
syndicats
c'est vraiment dommage en fait Nicolas
je voulais vous montrer la Une de Libé
c'était on l'a vu cette semaine
l'écrasant Monsieur Mélenchon partenaire
intéressant excédé et elle est fi est
divisée peut-on lire dans le sous-titre
c'était donc un cette semaine dans le
journal de gauche qu'est-ce que ça vous
évoque vous je crois qu'effectivement il
y a une petite confusion parce que dans
le effectivement le désordre de
l'Assemblée c'est pas la nupesse c'est
les filles et donc
on voit bien d'ailleurs que les
partenaires de LFI dans la nuitée
en grand malaise donc le paradoxe
aujourd'hui c'est celui qui a pointé
lamberger c'est-à-dire qu'on a des
manifestations massives dans la rue et
qui se passe bien et qui pour le coup
sont dignes et cohérentes et que le et
que le Parlement a dysfonctionné de
manière majeure là où pour rejoindre
c'est que il est clair que pour moi il y
a au-delà de du côté tactique je pense
qu'il y a un vrai problème
constitutionnel à utiliser
l'article alors
on s'est constitutionnel qui tranchera
mais pour moi la réforme des retraites
on peut la prendre de quelques manières
que ce soit mais c'est pas un texte
budgétaire et donc il y a pas seulement
le problème de l'index des seniors donc
il y a cette question qui est posée qui
vont du coup pas rentrer dans un texte
budgétaire de parler plus longtemps en
fait ça aurait été le désordre par
exemple
dans le parlementarisme rationalisé il y
a beaucoup d'armes donc il faut être
clair en dehors du budget on peut
utiliser le 49-3 donc si on voulait
aller vite et être clair et qui est
quand même à débat de toute manière le
gouvernement pouvait s'il le souhaitait
utiliser le 49 3 - démocratique du coup
veut pas dire que on vous a pas entendu
là dessus
la faute à qui elle a fauche au
gouvernement qui a enclenché cette
procédure 47 ans qui donc contraint la
durée des débats et donc empêche les
débats selon Chloé donc c'est
anti-démocratique ou la faute à la
bordelisation organisée au sein des
musiques pareil fi non il y a
effectivement le jeu des délais voulu
par le gouvernement qui était dans une
stratégie où ils savent qu'ils peuvent
arriver à avoir une majorité
en contraignant un peu les choses soit
par le délai soit par le 49-3 je crois
que c'était leur stratégie donc ils
étaient dans leur dans leur jeu et de
l'autre côté la France insoumise a eu
comme stratégie celle qu'il pensait être
la plus efficace auparavant qu'ils ont
fait déjà plusieurs fois qui était de
faire une de la déposant beaucoup
d'amendements pour ralentir la procédé
sauf que comme précisément les
manifestations étaient dignes comme
précisément il y avait un débat
médiatique assez intéressant avec des
arguments échangés de part et
voilà les gens avaient envie d'aller au
fond et c'est ça qui a en fait à la fin
débouchés sur ce télescopage ou la
France insoumise effectivement est jugée
responsable des débordements comme par
ailleurs sont frustrés voilà comme par
ailleurs il y a eu un certain nombre
d'échanges de noms oiseaux pas seulement
de la France insoumise Sandrine Rousseau
aussi a eu une attitude un petit peu
comment dirais-je brutale dans les
débats voilà donc tout ça a débouché sur
ce sur ce blocage et d'une certaine
manière une absurdité démocratique qui
est que la chambre ne se retrouve pas
aller au fond alors même la réalité vous
avez demandé la parole très rapidement
juste d'un point de vue institutionnel
ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est quand
même pas très brillant quand on a un
projet de loi on a en réalité examiné et
voter que deux arts il y en a un sur
deux qui a été rejeté donc ce texte est
envoyé et en réalité c'est pour ça qu'on
est quand même sur cette chaîne c'est ça
veut dire que par ailleurs c'est le
Sénat c'est le Sénat c'est le Sénat qui
va faire la loi voilà à partir de la
semaine prochaine c'est là qu'il va
faire la loi et c'est le conseil
le juge de la procédure est-ce que je
voulais dire c'est que heureusement dans
dans cette modélisation dont vous
parliez excusez-moi du terme il va y
avoir 11 jours de débat au Sénat et mon
Paris aujourd'hui c'est que si en jour
vont être beaucoup plus constructif et
vont apporter beaucoup plus à la
réflexion nationale et au débat
démocratique que ce qui s'est
malheureusement passé pendant ces
quelques jours à l'Assemblée
LFI rapidement les tensions au sein même
de la Nupe ce qu'on a entendu des
critiques sur la stratégie de la France
insoumise au sein de cet accord
électoral et même la perspective d'un
futur acte 2 de l'union de la gauche
c'était sur notre plateau écoutez
c'était Sandrine Rousseau cette semaine
ta signe un peu la fin d'un acte 1 de la
ligne PS qui a fonctionné jusqu'à
présent qui était issu de l'élection
présidentielle et que maintenant nous
passons nous devons passer à un acte 2
mais en tous les cas au sein de
l'assemblée je pense qu'il va falloir
voir en effet comment manière dont nous
fonctionner voilà on voit les
écologistes Chloé qui sont critique de
ce qui s'est passé au sein de la nuque
cette semaine c'est 15 jours oui parce
qu'ils ont je suis pas à l'intérieur de
leur groupe je sais pas comment ça se
passe mais je lis les journaux et je
vois que ils ont l'impression de pas
avoir été écouté mais l'acte 2 c'est un
déchirement de la nuque sans vous non ça
fait ça fait ça fait plus de 6 mois
maintenant que on dit toutes les
semaines que la nuque se centre déchire
jusqu'à présent ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas arrivé je sais je savais pas prédire
si si cette crise est plus grave que que
d'autres c'est un accord électoral de
circonstances
et ensuite à la présidentielle à la
législative et ensuite qui va buter sur
les élections suivantes donc ça c'est de
la même manière que l'alliance syndicale
est-elle aussi une alliance de
circonstances il est pas du tout sûr que
la CFDT et la CGT et même la CFTC vont
continuer ensuite à travailler de
conserve donc on a vouloir dire en fait
des choses qui sont malgré tout très
limitées dans le temps très rapide de
conclusion
quand il y a eu la constitution de de la
nuque on a dit le PS et même les verres
n'aurait peut-être pas dû être là dedans
au-delà de l'accord externe pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont destinés avec des
parties de gouvernement LFI est destinée
à être un parti de de révolte de
contradiction et ce qui s'est passé là
pendant ces quelques jours à l'Assemblée
la montrer plus que jamais pardon
les retraites mais excusez-moi il n'y
aurait pas eu de débat de fond sur les
1200 euros qui en fait
sur le fait que cette cette réforme soit
contre les femmes et défavorable plus
aux femmes etc il y a eu énormément de
choses qui ont été débunker grâce à
l'opposition de la nuque donc faut
arrêter de construire un récit qui est
contredit par les faits je suis désolé
il y a eu un débat de fond voilà
on avance la semaine dernière sur ce
plateau on se demandait où était
Emmanuel Macron et bien après des
semaines de diète médiatique le
président de la République est enfin
sorti du silence objectif pour le chef
de l'État sortir de la séquence retraite
mais en évoquant la valeur travail
écoutez le prénom République en visite
au marché de Rungis c'est un message de
reconnaissance d'abord devant toutes
celles et ceux
qui de
tourner vous savez on a beaucoup parlé
pendant le covid de cette France qui qui
tenait qui était là qui nous permettait
de continuer à aller faire les courses à
nous alimenter elle est là et c'est
celle aussi aujourd'hui qui malgré un
contexte d'inflation et difficile et là
pour là on est à la viande mais c'est
pareil au frais et légumes au fromage
aux poissons etc elle tient et c'est ce
travail qui nous permet de vivre est-ce
que je veux dire ici c'est que le vrai
débat qu'on a à voir dans la société
c'est un travail
alors je vous propose un duel sur ce
plateau c'est une petite habitude de
l'émission vous êtes deux je crois
autour de cette table va pas être
d'accord sur le fait qu'Emmanuel Macron
incarne ou pas cette valeur travail
c'est vous Nicolas et c'est vous Fabrice
vous avez 45 secondes chacun pour
défendre votre avis alors Fabrice vous
pouvez commencer un carnet-il cette
valeur travail Emmanuel Macron sur vous
bah il cherche un incarner il veut
l'incarner pour deux raisons simples
d'abord il y a la question des retraites
qui le poussent à dire qu'il faut
travailler plus longtemps à mettre en
avant des arguments justement de durée
j'essaie de regarder mon chrono pour pas
me faire le deuxième élément qui fait
que Macron veut mettre en avant le
travail c'est effectivement les bons
résultats qu'il a eu sur le chômage qui
lui permettent de se targuer du fait que
la France est une France aujourd'hui
active et donc il essaye aussi d'avancer
dans cette optique la difficulté c'est
que il incarne le travail j'allais dire
de la version d'avant c'est à dire un
petit peu dans une logique sarkozyte
puisque Sarkozy l'inspire d'une certaine
manière quand on entend parler la France
qui se lève tôt c'est un petit peu ça
travailler plus dit-il on a presque
envie de dire que il voudrait on gagne
plus même si c'est pas le cas la grosse
difficulté c'est que cette conception du
travail est aujourd'hui remise en cause
merci bravo 45 secondes et alors vous
Nicolas vous dites en fait tout ça c'est
de la com oui je crois que ça tient
beaucoup de la diversion et que derrière
il y a quand même
cette idée de France qui se lève tôt ou
de
d'expliquer que en permanence finalement
que le les Français seraient définiant
et en réalité quand on regarde les
choses en termes de taux d'emploi en
termes de y compris de durée du travail
la partie de la France qui travaille en
réalité elle travaille elle travaille
plutôt très dur donc je crois que ce
discours sur le non travail est un
discours en réalité qui est un discours
qui qui est faux et qui ne correspond
pas au fait merci alors Valérie je
voyais réagir pendant ces explications
oui qu'est-ce que vous savez
n'a pas tort parce que en fait ce qui a
fait apparaître le débat des retraites
c'est qu'il aurait fallu avoir un débat
sur le travail sur le sens du travail
sur le sens du travail sur la pénibilité
au travail sur les difficultés il y a
une étude qui est sortie disant qu'en
France les gens qui travaillent
souffrent plus que dans les autres pays
d'Europe
et donc pas sur effectivement le travail
pour les Français alors quand on disait
le monde a changé effectivement vous
aviez totalement raison et le premier
sujet ou le monde a changé c'est dans le
travail enfin la société a changé dans
le travail c'était ne veut plus
aujourd'hui travailler à tout prix à
n'importe quelle condition
on a fait les choses à l'envers
notamment les jeunes notamment les
jeunes mais pas que oui on a oublié le
débat sur la valeur du travail avec la
sortie de Macron à Rungis déjà il y a un
vocabulaire qui pour moi est
insupportable sur le plaisir les gens
savent le peuple sait que il faut
travailler plus longtemps c'est une
manière d'étouffer le débat et de dire
voilà il y a j'ai la raison pour moi et
puis circuler il y a rien à voir le
peuple sait les gens savent pas
et puis il y a aussi le fait
qu'effectivement en fond de tout ça à
vouloir il y a une forme d'anachronisme
dans ce discours à marteler la valeur
travail je sais le travail n'est pas une
valeur c'est à la limite un droit et un
droit à l'emploi en France et puis il y
a un droit aussi au repos aux loisirs il
y a un droit à travailler de façon
décente et d'une façon qui ne qui ne
fasse pas à souffrir ni le corps ni
l'esprit en tout cas pas de façon
insupportable et donc effectivement
plutôt que de marteler ça la valeur
travail comme ça de façon un peu creuse
il faut s'attacher aux conditions de
travail en France qui selon les études
de la DARES se dégradent effectivement
et à la place du qu'occupe le travail
dans la vie des Français qui est moins
importante qu'avant on est une société
où le travail permet toujours de se
définir dans la vie ça a une importance
et immense bien sûr pour les Français
c'est aussi une
la dignité passe par par l'emploi mais
on peut pas que le travail c'est pas
toute notre vie et on veut travailler
moins et on veut travailler
non rapidement je voudrais pas qu'il y
ait d'ambiguïté je pense qu'il faut
travailler plus longtemps je suis
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut reculer
l'âge de la retraite parce que
mécaniquement on peut pas continuer
comme ça il peut pas y avoir un actif
pour un retraité ça marche pas il y a
pas de possibilité de solution et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut redonner une vraie
valeur très fort au travail et du sens
au travail pour que les gens aient le
goût du travail qu'ils aient envie
d'être travaillé et que de ce fait ils
aient envie d'aller travailler plus
longtemps que ce soit pas la punition
quand vous voyez dans les manifestations
métro boulot caveau ou tombeau
rapide d'abord sur la question du
chômage il faut quand même être prudent
parce que c'est vrai qu'il a diminué à
7,2 %
des pays développés sont en pleine
emploi et avec des niveaux de chômage
qui sont inférieurs de mouettes prudent
là dessus
la deuxième chose sur le sur le travail
c'est que bien sûr il y a le volume du
travail mais le plus important c'est la
productivité
et donc et là elle est en baisse en
France et effectivement le le problème
considérable et ce qui explique notre
décrochage vis-à-vis de beaucoup de pays
c'est que la productivité aujourd'hui
enfin les gains de productivité sont
quasiment nuls voire négatifs depuis le
covid et ça c'est terrible parce que ça
c'est vraiment ça veut dire qu'il y a
plus de croissance potentielle dans un
pays quand il y a plus de gain de
productivité mais voilà je crois qu'on
était un des pays je croyais qu'on était
un des pays qui par rapport à l'ensemble
de l'OCDE en volume global de travail
est ben oui mais qui était un de ceux
dans lequel il y avait le plus faible
volume de travail global non mais la
productivité la productivité était assez
haute mais le problème c'est que elle
était haute mais elle stagne alors que
là par exemple de travail en volume de
travail on est loin derrière les
Américains loin dernièrement et il me
semble même qu'on est derrière les
Italiens
si on prend des chiffres le
taux d'emploi multiplié par
la durée de vie pendant laquelle on
travaille et ensuite le nombre d'heures
travaillées c'est vrai que on reste on a
des plus
on est au niveau de des à peu près des
Allemands effectivement finalement
beaucoup plus bas qu'aux États-Unis ou
que juste non mais là dessus sur la
question de la productivité
effectivement je vous rejoins ces
capitales c'est important c'est
là-dessus qu'on doit s'étalonner de ce
productivité qu'on doit essayer de
réfléchir et il y a justement une étude
récente qui nous vient du Royaume-Uni
qui a été faite sur une expérimentation
de la semaine de quatre jours dans
certaines entreprises je dis pas que ça
peut s'étendre à l'ensemble des secteurs
de la société mais qui montrent que
cette semaine de quatre jours permet
d'augmenter la productivité en gardant
le même nombre d'heures travaillées le
temps de travail il y a quand même un
dernier sujet c'est la répartition entre
les profits des entreprises et le
travail la redistribution en faveur du
travail et pas assez importante en
France par rapport aux très très bons
résultats qu'on a vu récemment c'est à
dire que les salaires les salaires il va
falloir un jour qu'on arrive à augmenter
les salaires depuis les 35 heures en
fait et 35 heures ont entraîné une
stagnation des salaires parce que les
gens ont gardé un salaire égal pour
travailler moins et on a un retard de
salaire dans ce pays qui est très très
mal vécu par la population combien il y
a de personnes en France qui travaillent
et qui n'ont pas de quoi payer leur vie
en fait et bien un autre conclusion
allez-y rapidement juste pour le
effectivement le l'étude chez les
Britanniques en fait c'est pas une
réduction du temps de travail c'est du
travail sur quatre jours et moi je suis
absolument je suis absolument pour une
meuf flexibilité qui soit maximale il y
a des endroits dans l'industrie ou dans
les services où on peut être mieux
organisé ça correspond mieux aux
souhaits des gens et par ailleurs quand
on gagne de la productivité mais pour le
coup il faut laisser beaucoup plus de
latitude dans les entreprises avec
évidemment un dialogue social qui
permette de définir des solutions
au cas par cas et ce qui compte c'est le
résultat final c'est la productivité de
passer au troisième thème dans cette
émission et elle est LR qui se déchirent
à nouveau la nouvelle direction a
pourtant été nommée il y a seulement un
mois c'était le 18 janvier Aurélien
Pradier avait obtenu la confortable
place de numéro 2 du parti mais le
désaccord du député du lot sur les
formes des retraites a eu raison de
cette Concorde en interne Aurélien
Pradier a été limite ses fonctions le
week-end dernier il a réagi avec ce
tweet je préfère la liberté de
conviction à un poste quelconque ma
parole est franche et elle le restera
qu'est-ce qui se joue encore chez les LR
il se joue Aurélien Pradier qui avait
envie d'attirer la lumière sur lui
surtout je pense parce que en fait
sincèrement il était le premier à prôner
un allongement de la durée avant de
l'âge légal pour la retraite et quand la
réforme a été présentée il a
complètement fait machin arrière et à
adopter une position beaucoup plus
souple et surtout la façon sur laquelle
le sujet des 43 annuités avant 21 ans
après 21 ans etc enfin on se souvient
même plus du détail me semble marginal
par rapport à l'effet global de cette de
cette brouille en fait entre le nouveau
président de LR et Aurélien Pradier
c'est un petit peu c'est une question de
personne ou est-ce que derrière il y a
un désaccord idéologique au sein du
parti bon ils ont été en concurrence
pour la présence du parti c'est vrai
avec sotti et Aurélien padre mais il y a
quand même je crois quand même qu'il y a
il y a deux logiques qui qui se crochent
chez les LR et qui les mettent en
tension il y a la logique j'allais dire
de l'état-major incarné par sciotique
qui se dit si on veut manifester qu'on
est encore un parti de gouvernement il
faut malgré tout qu'on joue le jeu
stratégiquement à certains moments sur
des réformes clés
et qu'on manifeste que c'est par nous
que ça passe et voilà bon et puis de
l'autre côté il y a ceux qui sont
confrontés aux électeurs et qui ont des
électeurs qui sont souvent plus radicaux
plus dans l'opposition à Macron assez
virulente qui ont le sentiment que rien
n'est fait sous Macron et donc la
Pradier il vient d'une circonscription
c'est comme ça donc il se dit si je
lâche là dessus derrière c'est la
débâcle derrière chez battu donc ils
sont obligés à un moment donné de
rentrer en dans ces stratégies
d'opposition qui peuvent paraître un peu
un peu injuste un peu malhonnête un peu
un peu de circonstances que en fait
manifeste les besoins sur le fait que
effectivement il y a ces électeurs qui
et bien reprochent à leur partie d'être
la béquille de la macronie c'est
peut-être ça que Aurélien Pradier a
représenté dans cette séquence si vous
voulez tout vient d'un paradoxe
incroyable pour la droite c'est-à-dire
que elle sort d'une défaite électorale
historique moins de 5% à la
présidentielle et un nombre de députés
réduits à 62 donc pratiquement la la
perte de la moitié du groupe de l'autre
côté à cause de cette situation de
majorité relative c'est vrai que son
pivots ils sont ils sont pas pivots ils
sont indispensables si avec le rôle des
62 députés et surtout
en réalité la capacité à trouver une
majorité aussi a besoin de 42 députés
pour avoir la majorité absolue
la macronie ne peut faire passer de
texte que avec les LR que avec et si
vous voulez elle résulte de ça c'est que
derrière ce parti donc il est écarte en
politique qu'est-ce qu'il faut avoir il
faut avoir un leader un projet une
stratégie leader on pensait que c'était
réglé avec
cioti derrière Wauquiez et maintenant en
fait évidemment avec Pradier Xavier
Bertrand a ressurgi donc en réalité ils
sont repartis dans un conflit de chef le
projet ils n'en ont plus depuis 2007 et
la stratégie c'est l'écart tellement
entre eux l'Union des droites version
Zemmour
et de l'autre côté le rapprochement avec
le les et donc aujourd'hui
c'est Jean-François Copé écoutez son
analyse un cycle la réaction de la
sénatrice salaire Valérie Boyer alors
elle elle est proche de François Fillon
et elle a soutenu avec ce type pendant
la campagne interne écoutez ces deux
extraits si la droite veut reconquérir
une crédibilité vis-à-vis des Français
c'est pas en étant populiste c'est pas
en épousant les idées de Madame Le Pen
ou de Monsieur Mélenchon parce que pour
le coup les extrémistes feront toujours
mieux que nous et donc en réalité la
seule manière pour nous de retrouver une
incarnation politique pour la droite de
gouvernement par opposition d'extrême
droite populiste c'est de dire mais nous
on veut faire ça pour l'avenir de la
France je crois que il se plaignait de
ne pas qu'il n'y ait pas de chef à
droite je pense qu'il a eu il a vu qu'il
y avait un chef à droite vous avez à
partir d'un certain moment je pense que
nous ne sommes pas un parti caporalisé
loin de là mais il y avait une ligne qui
avait été adoptée et je pense que c'est
une bonne chose moi ce que je souhaite
maintenant c'est que on passe vraiment
un débat sérieux sur le fond vous n'êtes
pas du tout revenu sur ce sujet depuis
le début que ça vous évoque vous
le fait que vous dites la droite a subi
une défaite majeure à la dernière
élection moins de 5%, je suis pas
d'accord LR n'a pas le monopole de la
droite Macron a remporté l'élection et
ça fait moins de 5 % parce que avec
Macron elle avait le même programme donc
ils se sont neutralisés donc en fait ce
que cette histoire montre c'est
simplement que la droite n'assume pas
que en fait Macron applique sa politique
et donc se déchire sur des espèces de
querelles assez artificielles où on
essaie à tout prix de se démarquer côté
Aurélien pratique pour dire on s'oppose
au gouvernement alors qu'en réalité il
soutiennent sa politique
je voulais rajouter par rapport à ce
qu'a dit Fabrice et qui était chez tout
à fait d'accord avec lui la clé tout ça
c'est que ces fameux 60 députés LR ils
sont tous ruraux autrefois
c'est la clé de tout ce que tu es en
train de se passer parce que autrefois
elle est quand il est autant de leur
splendeur et que ils avaient plein de
députés dans toutes les grandes villes
il y avait des députés LR à Paris à Lyon
à Marseille dans toutes les grandes
villes cette fois-ci parmi les 62
députés il y en a aucun c'est une autre
d'aller soutenir la réforme des
retraites parce que c'est leur ADN qui
soutient pas à la réforme pour
l'appareil et c'est pas le tissu des
militants là aussi le monde a changé
parce que c'est députés ruraux ils
écoutent qui ils écoutent d'abord leur
électoratoires
dans les lieux où la réforme des
retraites passe le plus mal parce que
c'est là que les conditions de travail
sont les plus difficiles
on a eu le plus de manifs et où les gens
ne veulent pas retarder l'âge donc c'est
ça l'explication profonde en fait c'est
celle là le fait d'abord et lui elle
sera dur à trouver cette majorité pour
le gouvernement le gouvernement va avoir
du mal à trouver sa majorité certains ne
viendront pas voter chez les LR le jour
où il faudra voter sur la fin du texte
de la réforme nationale ils iront
ailleurs ils prennent pas cet engagement
ce risque là si on effectivement les
conclusions si on dépasse un peu juste
le texte sur les retraites il y a quand
même deux grandes conclusions la
première c'est qu'effectivement je pense
que le Emmanuel Macron a un problème
majeur de de majorité pour tout ce qui
est pas de 49-3 et que sur les autres
textes ça sera de plus en plus compliqué
et puis il y a quand même avec
l'immigration ensuite il y a quand même
un effet ce qu'on a dit de dégradation
des institutions avec une accélération
qui est spectaculaire on a un président
qui gouverne au lieu de de
présider on a un gouvernement qui fait
des éléments de langage au lieu de
regarder et un parlement qui n'est
capable ni de voter la loi ni de
contrôler le gouvernement ni de débattre
de manière à peu près apaisée donc ça
fait quand même un panorama pour le
moins inquiète en mode conclusion faut
pas procéder trop par amalgame gauche
droite gauche droite mais il y a des
couleurs différentes les macronistes ne
se considèrent pas comme une droite que
vous voulez regarder comme une analyse
comme ça oui peut-être mais il existe
une droite mais il existe considère pas
comme ça
il existe une droite il faut pas faire
comme si on avait pas ils sont là c'est
une famille de pensée c'est une famille
de penser non mais pas qu'on sonne
droite c'est des logiques un peu
différente sinon on comprend pas
pourquoi il y a eu Giscard pourquoi il y
a une chiracle il s'en est rapproché il
s'en est rapproché Bruno Le Maire aussi
il s'en sort ils sont allés vers cette
tradition là et en fait est-ce que
j'essaie juste de ce que j'essaie juste
de dire c'est que cette famille
politique justement de droite elle est
en elle est
il y en a il y en a un certain nombre
d'ailleurs on les voit on les voit
aujourd'hui on les voit aujourd'hui
s'exprimer et il y en a un certain
nombre et on va aller voir sur d'autres
textes que qui tiennent justement vivre
ensemble à la question de la laïcité à
la question de l'immigration où on va
voir s'exprimer d'autres d'autres
familles ce qui est très important c'est
que la recomposition actuelle on pensait
que c'était réglé derrière vos pieds ce
qu'on constate c'est pas seulement
pratique mais c'est qu'on voit l'isnard
aussi on voit différentes et c'est pas
que des problèmes de personnes c'est
aussi des visions du pays qui se qui
sachent qui s'échappent et qui
reviennent allez dernier thème dans
cette émission on découvre pas à
l'action de certains lobby dans la
sphère politique mais ces derniers jours
l'affaire mbarky a surpris par son
ampleur journaliste de BFM TV et
suspecté leur donner à l'antenne des
informations venues d'un lobier étranger
il a été licencié le BFM TV en fin de
semaine la chaîne porte plein de contrix
pour un but confiance et corruption
passive alors qu'est-ce que ça dit cette
affaire un bar qui de l'influence de ces
lobbies et on les avait pas suspecté
aussi important écoutez je pense que les
lob en France ils existent c'est évident
je veux dire chaque entreprise quand il
y a un débat entre les agriculteurs et
la grande distribution il y a le lobby
des agriculteurs d'un côté il y a le
billet de la grande distribution de
l'autre à chaque fois qu'il y a un grand
débat en France avec des positions
opposées il y a des lobbies simplement
cette affaire là en particulier elle est
très différente
bien sûr qu'elle est extrêmement grave
c'est-à-dire c'est c'est des gens qui
sont quand même payés par des
gouvernements étrangers etc pour
diffuser des images contre toute
organisation d'une chaîne de télévision
directement auprès du grand public mais
c'est pour ça que le mot de lobby me
gêne un petit peu parce qu'il ne
reprennent
c'est pas exactement la même chose si
vous voulez de défendre un point de vue
avec quelque chose d'organisé ou d'aller
contrevenir à la loi et de balancer des
images pour servir la cause de quelqu'un
effectivement derrière le lobby il y a
la volonté de défendre des intérêts
économiques tout ce que vous voulez là
le terme est mal choisi parce que il
s'agit de quoi il s'agit de
désinformations
donc c'est pas une logique de rapport de
force pour défendre ses intérêts c'est
une logique de déstabilisation en
répondant des fausses informations et
c'est une ingérence étrangère et donc
c'est très grave et ça a peut-être
favorise la prise de conscience qui est
toujours en cours que la France l'Europe
sont déstabilisés et sont frappés par
par des gens qui essaient de nous mener
une guerre de l'information et donc il
faut il faut y répondre
plus résolument plutôt que des
entreprises ont influencé les élections
américaines de 2016 ou encore la
campagne référendaire du brexit la même
année on a toujours pas compris on n'a
toujours pas pris en compte la gravité
de ces influences étrangères non c'est
enfin pour moi il y a deux logiques
différentes il y a les lobbies les
lobbies qui existent depuis l'aube de la
révolution industrielle en France aux
entreprises qui pèsent bon d'accord
aujourd'hui la question à laquelle on
est confronté c'est qu'il y a des
infrastructures il y a des outils il y a
des agences il y a des entreprises
spécifiques qui viennent troubler le jeu
de l'opinion publique comme vous l'avez
dit et à la fois sur j'allais dire le
citoyen lambda en passant par les
réseaux sociaux puisqu'elle s'appuie
beaucoup sur ces logiques là pour
reprendre un petit passage d'émissions
ils ont bien souligné ça les
journalistes de Radio France en
présentant leur enquête mais
l'infrastructure va plus loin parce que
ça pèse aussi sur les décideurs on a vu
que là il y avait un député qui était en
cause on a vu aussi auparavant que il y
a eu des parlementaires européens qui
ont fait l'objet donc le problème c'est
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour lutter
contre excusez-moi chers camarade
certaines entreprises qui vont plus loin
que la communication et rentre dans des
logiques qui sont hybrides entre la
corruption et l'influence la plus la
plus délétère c'est à dire que ce sont
des officines particulières qui bah
forcément je suis d'accord ce que vous
avez dit et c'est pas du lobbying c'est
de la désinformation c'est totalement
différent il y a une affaire dans
l'affaire là où il faut trouver le
député écologiste Hubert Julien et la
Ferrière qui a fait publiquement la
promotion à l'Assemblée nationale d'un
homme d'affaire camerounais aujourd'hui
soupçonné d'être organisateur d'une
fraude massive au crypto-monnaies en
Afrique donc ce député qui a voilà
défendu cela dans une salle de
commission au sein même de l'Assemblée
nationale on écoute en extrait regardé
je voudrais vous faire part de mes
impressions que j'ai eu en écoutant une
émission de RFI tout récemment sur sur
les crypto monnaie sur le rôle des
crypto-monnaies dans les pays en
développement et RFI montrer l'exemple
de cette entrepreneur camerounais et
Émile parfait Sims qui a développé une
monnaie alternative le limocoï avec le
projet exclusé du peu de créer une
nouvelle ville auto gérée sur les rives
de l'océan Atlantique lui dit juste
avoir été influencé mais Mediapart
l'ulgare parle de voilà d'une
organisation guidé par le même lobbyiste
et que ça évoque vous le Parlement
français qui est donc comme cela au cœur
de la faire aussi en fait on est à peu
près tous d'accord c'est que d'abord
c'est tout à fait normal qui est des
lobbies dans une société développée que
des et d'ailleurs c'est mieux que les
intérêts voilà absolument de leur point
de vue il y a deux conditions il faut
que ce soit transparent et puis à
l'inverse depuis très longtemps on sait
qu'il y a des mécaniques de corruption
regardez le scandale de Panama on avait
déjà des intérêts économiques qui
achetaient des journalistes et qui
achetaient des
parlementaires et enfin 19e siècle parce
que sinon avec les panamas papers tu vas
créer une confusion voilà bon donc ça
c'est très ancien il y a deux choses il
y a une chose qui est effectivement
nouvelle c'est qu'aujourd'hui avec la
technologie c'est la puissance de la
désinformation donc autrement dit il est
tout à fait normal qu'il y ait des
lobbies il faut simplement qu'il soit
transparent et que ce soit régulé
et ensuite il faut il faut évidemment
lutter contre la corruption donc ce
qu'on a vu au Parlement européen est
très grave c'est vrai que ça a montré
au-delà de la dérive des personnes en
cause qui avait un vrai problème ce
qu'on savait depuis longtemps au
Parlement européen où on a les deux
c'est-à-dire que on a vraiment des gens
qui se via des ONG qui est typiquement
ce qui s'est passé des fausses ONG qui
cachent des intérêts de certains états
et qui défendent des positions qui sont
des positions en plus de détails qui
sont très clairement aujourd'hui nos
adversaires donc les législation sur la
transparence
au Parlement européen à la lumière du
scandale sur le
Qatar qui avait donné de l'argent contre
à des députés contre l'Espérance d'un
vote en sa faveur favorable
jusqu'à reconnaître qu'il y avait pas
d'infraction enfin de
que le Qatar ne se rendait pas coupable
d'infraction vers les droits de l'homme
donc c'est quand même très grave et on a
bien vu que c'était pas suffisant et que
pour ce qui concernait on avait fait un
registre de transparence pour les lobbys
commerciaux mais pour ce qui est des
ingérences étrangères il y avait rien
c'est-à-dire que on interdisait pas et
on ne demandait pas au député européen
de renseigner sur un registre les
puissances étrangères et les
représentants de puissance étrangères
qu'il rencontrait donc là il y avait ce
qu'on appelle un trou dans la raquette
pardonnez-moi l'expression et je crois
que il y a plusieurs propositions qui
ont émergé à la faveur de ce scandale
notamment celle de créer une haute
autorité de la transparence au niveau
européen
comme chaque semaine on termine
l'émission par un top flop je repose à
chacun une question simple quelle est la
personnalité qui a marqué l'actualité en
bien et en mal vous pouvez commencer
Chloé s'il vous plaît votre top
justement c'était l'étude très
intéressante qui a été faite donc autour
de l'expérimentation de la semaine de
quatre jours dans certaines entreprises
au Royaume-Uni et qui montrent que cette
réduction de temps de travail sans perte
de salaire entraîne une forte réduction
du stress des démissions qui sont un
coup important pour les entreprises
parce que c'est les coups de formation
des coûts de recrutement et avec une
augmentation constatée du chiffre
d'affaires sur sur la même période à
hauteur de 1 plus 1,3% de chiffre
d'affaires et en conclusion de cette
expérimentation vous avez 92% des
entreprises qui l'ont testées la semaine
de quatre jours qui ont décidé de
prolonger l'expérience et 30% qui ont
décidé d'adopter la semaine de quatre
jours de façon définitive
et mon flop c'est le fait que le
Président de la République Emmanuel
Macron est
décoré Jeff Bezos qui est PDG d'Amazon
de la Légion d'Honneur je trouve que
c'est incompréhensible de décorer un
homme qui participe de la dégradation
des conditions de travail en France
puisque dans les entrepôts Amazon c'est
une dés une déshumanisation du travail
au sens propre à laquelle nous nous
assistons ou les les êtres humains les
piqueurs de colis sont transformés en
robots et dirigé par des robots et puis
c'est aussi une activité Amazon qui
détruit de l'emploi en France notamment
dans les librairies Fabrice d'Almeida le
top ou flop comme vous voulez on peut
commencer par le top allons-y on
commence par le stop moi c'est les
agriculteurs je vous les saluer parce
qu'aujourd'hui
d'Aquitaine avec leur charolaise quand
ils viennent à Paris
j'aime beaucoup ça et je dois avouer que
ce salon de l'agriculture qui est d'une
certaine manière une fête populaire mais
un mérite chaque année un petit coup
d'oeil une petite visite alors mon flop
c'est une passion triste de la société
française c'est tout ce qu'il y a autour
de ce fait divers que constitue
l'affaire Palmade je suis étonné à quel
point nous nous laissons fasciner par
ses affaires
et il quelque chose là-dedans qui me
paraît qui me paraît presque malsain
dans ce regard qu'on se jette sur
nous-mêmes Valérie vous voulez commencer
avec votre j'ai deux flops
c'était possible aussi le premier c'est
la sécheresse en France voilà c'est
quand même extrêmement préoccupant on a
eu 31 jours 30 pluies 32 jours sans
pluie c'est ça n'arrive pas souvent
c'est ça commence à devenir répétitif et
je trouve ça extrêmement extrêmement
préoccupant notamment pour vos
agriculteurs que vous aimez beaucoup et
qui ont beaucoup besoin d'eau et donc
j'espère que ça va s'arranger que ça va
continuer c'est une émotion particulière
enfin je voulais quand même dire un mot
de cette professeur qui a été assassiné
professeur d'espagnol qui alors bon
c'est un fait divers qui est qui est
particulier parce que malheureusement ce
jeune n'était pas en possession de sa
raison psychiatrique on va dire mais
c'est quelque chose qui devrait pas
arriver d'avoir un représentant de
l'enseignement dans ce pays tué alors
qu'en plus c'était une femme formidable
apparemment de ce que tout le monde dit
Nicolas
oui c'est peut-être la période qui veut
ça mais la première c'est le la décision
de l'Union européenne de proscrire la
construction d'interdire la construction
des véhicules thermiques en 2035 c'est
pas cette décision que je trouve en
elle-même choquante mais c'est le fait
que il y a aucune réflexion aucune
évaluation donc si on veut avoir de la
voiture électrique il faut deux choses
il faut de l'électricité propre on
reprend l’instant c'est absolument pas
le cas et on régresse il faut des
infrastructures
c'est effectivement ce qui s'est passé à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz et d'une manière
générale ce qui se passe sur l'éducation
nationale on a aujourd'hui un
effondrement complet de ce système on a
la violence qui s'installe dans ces
établissements et il n'y a aucune
politique digne de ce nom qui s'attaque
à la chose qui est la plus importante
qui est la qualité de l'enseignement et
c'est pour l'éducation comme vraiment
pour la santé ou même chose personne ne
s'intéresse à la qualité des soins et
c'est vraiment extrêmement dommage
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
tous les quatre merci à vous chers
téléspectateurs et à nos auditeurs
carrément est également disponible en
podcast sur les plateformes retour de
Steve Jourdain très prochainement très
belle suite des programmes sont Félix
[Musique]